Okay.
Hey, what's going on? Is Bill Burn?
It's time for the Monday morning
podcast for Monday, May 1st,
2017 what's going on?
How
you liked that echo?
I am in my garage.
This is what it's come down to.
It's like fucking a quarter to seven
or 10 and seven in the morning.
I got to go to the airport.
My lovely daughter was sleeping.
My wife is sleeping. There is no place
in the house, so me to scream and yell.
So I'm out here in the garage and
oh by the way, in less than a mile,
but an hour around eight o'clock.
There's people coming
to my house cause I'm,
well, you know the gas line is,
I dunno, 96 years fucking old.
It needs to be replaced because it's
leaking all over the goddamn place.
Um, that's always fun to
have a baby in your hands.
You set it down towards the floor and
he kept to say things DYF like, um,
do you smell gas?
So I'm getting that taken care
of today and uh, this is it.
This is where my life is at.
So I'm sitting here on
my workout bench that uh,
I can't use cause I fucked up my shoulder.
It's gradually getting better.
This is the longest, most nagging
fucking injury ever to try to heal.
But I'm almost there and um,
this is how I'm going to do with people.
This is how I'm going to celebrate.
This is the 10 year anniversary
of the Monday morning podcast.
Can you believe that for 10 years
I have been yapping to myself,
you know, 10 years. I have
not been reading 10 years.
I had been making up shit for 10 years.
I've been saying shit that I thought was
true cause I heard somebody say it in
an airport. I've been doing
that for 10 years. Um,
I want to thank everybody who's been
listening and I'm going to put a link to a
post, whatever the fuck
you guys say. It's,
it's a thing that you click on and then
it goes to the video that you want to
watch. What will be the, um, the
first Monday morning podcast ever,
which I believe was about 90 seconds long.
I'll give you a little history.
I was over a Robert
Kelly's apartment back.
We still live right around the corner
of each other when I was still living in
New York City and it was over his
house and he was just, you know,
it was typical Bob. He was just like, hey,
you should do a podcast gig.
This isn't to May of 2007 one of the few
things I've ever been at the beginning
of podcasting and getting
a special on Netflix.
Those are the two things I was
at the front. Like I remember,
you know, for my intro and comedy
clubs, I would say a, they like,
what do you want to say? Oh, say
he's been on this, he's been on that.
And you can see he might've seen his
specials on Netflix and the host would say
it and people would snicker.
Yeah,
they'd laugh in the crowd. They'd laugh
at that credit. Well now look at it. Huh?
Look at the feed the
fucking world dominating.
You know these oil companies now
to look at Netflix like, God damn,
how the fuck did you do that
without firing a shot? How
the fuck did you do that?
Right. So Netflix, Netflix,
and podcasting, you know, if I was, if
I was on a, an oil company, I would, uh,
I said I would do, I would start
coming up with some original content,
you know what I mean? And just
make the show so amazing, you know,
that the stars would then go over to
those countries and while everybody was
fawning over the cast of
the reboot of friends,
I would then run around the corner and I
would start stealing their oil. That's,
that's how I would do it. You know,
it's a lot less messy. You don't,
there's excitement. Am I
going to get caught? Right?
Yeah.
Um, anyways, back in the day, so I'm
over Brava Kelly's apartment. He's like,
did he,
you should do a podcast.
And I was like, what is
a, what does a podcast
[inaudible] recording?
It's another way to connect
with your fears. Do, who knows?
Okay.
Now people listen to it.
You do in the stress factory
Tuesday to Sunday, dude.
And I'm literally just fucking around
on it. And I actually, I called it,
if you listen to my first podcast, he
listened to the link. I actually said it.
I said, ah, this is my podcast.
I was basically repeating everything
that Bobby was kinda yelling to me in the
background. And um, and I called it,
I said a and who knows, maybe this
might lead to something mediocre.
And you know what, it took me to
taking me 10 years, but God damn it,
I got there.
Here I am
sitting here and my fucking garage.
This is not some sort of cool
reverb that you listening to.
This is me and my garage.
Um,
you know what's amazing though
is I gotta tell you something.
I don't know what it is. It's, I'm such
a cliched guy. I fucking love the garage.
The garage is the shit.
You know what I mean?
It takes you back to being a single
man when you barely had anything.
Cause I have one of those fucking garages.
By the way,
I was not going to be the person that had
the garage. Right. That like you. Yeah.
Bye. Shit. And there's no more
room for this shit in your house.
And then you take some other shit that
you used to like and you stick it in a
box and then you stick it in the garage,
right and gradually starts encroaching
on the car and next thing you know,
the car can't be in there and it just
fucking fills all the way up. Well,
you know what you're doing.
You're slowly becoming a fucking hoarder.
That's one of the saddest
things. I actually, you know,
I came at and understand whether
it's sad or whether it's, um,
you just taking responsibility for,
for all the shit that you
buy in your life. You know,
I guess anybody could take
it down to goodwill. Anybody
can throw it in the trash
take to the dump.
It takes a real caring human being,
a real caring human
being to just sit there
and [inaudible] and all that fucking shit.
You bought your entire life.
Every fucking newspaper,
every tube of toothpaste,
just sitting them suffocating in
your own fucking carbon footprint.
You know, I just realized, you know, we
shouldn't be looking down at hoarders.
We should be looking at these people
going like, Holy Shit, one human being,
one human being can buy
all of that shit and alive.
It's not even a lifetime.
They still live in, you know,
you can have that many pets,
fucking fish tags,
newspapers and all of
that crap. Um, I dunno,
I would happen. I'm sitting there
looking over right now. You know,
my neat little fucking garage.
I got like two different rooms.
I got this old fucking mop. I don't
even know where that thing came from.
I think it came with the house,
you know?
Yeah.
And I've been meaning to throw that
thing up. Where does it end up?
Huh?
Fucking in some beavers house.
Some stupid mop handles sticking through
his little sucking thatch of a roof.
All those things fast. By the way.
I get those giant Goddamn teeth.
Fucking horse teeth, dude. It's so they
can cut through the back dude. Anyways,
so it's been 10 years in.
Um, I'm actually, you know,
I had people on Twitter send in
some of their favorite moments,
which I'll be reading later if I could
somehow get this fucking computer to work
while I'm out here. Um, yeah. So anyways,
let's get on with the podcast.
So I didn't know if I even said it.
Thank you guys for listening.
Uh, throughout the years.
Thank you to everybody who's
booth advertised on the podcast,
whether you liked the read or you didn't,
whether you got upset and said that
I'm never going to advertise again.
Whatever it was, it was fun. A lot of fun.
So here's to the next 10 years,
I'm still not going to read,
right. I Dunno. Whatever.
You know what I liked though?
I'm a buck 76 right now.
I do like that the way 176 pounds.
So roughly the fucking way there was,
I was probably a few pounds lighter,
but I got to get down to it.
I got to get down the end of the
month, next month, my birthday,
I want to be like one 71 71. Right. And
you know what? I get down to that way.
I get down to that way. Guess
what? Then I'll be happy. Ah.
Then it will fill the void.
You know when I go on,
I put my little fucking tiger woods golf
shirt on even though I don't fucking
golf.
MMM.
Anyways. Is that fucking guy ever
going to win another tournament?
It really bugs me.
Really fucking bothers me that there's
a bunch of broads out there that think
the reason why he never want to another
fucking tournament was because of the
bullshit of his personal life.
Give me a fucking break.
His body broke down. That's what the
fuck happened. This guy's a champion.
Do you understand what the champion could
do? Champion can block anything out.
If you see these guys going up trying
to get the fucking free throws,
everybody just waving their hands,
screaming a bunch of shit about the guy's
wife. What does he do? Nothing but net.
Nothing but fucking net.
You know, sky can't handle.
A little spat gets hit with a golf club.
He jumps in his Escalade and he hits a
fucking Rose Bush and all of a sudden,
all of that talent goes away.
I don't know. I don't buy it.
I think the,
and I think the reason why some women,
some women look at me being a little
measured in the next 10 years.
Some women, the reason why I think they
attributed to that is because I, you know,
I think that they want to buy
into that whole fucking thing.
He's behind the like, man is a
good woman. You know what I mean?
Which is so fucking stupid,
right? Obviously if you have
a happy fucking marriage,
your life's going to be all right. But
that's just another fucking, you know,
everybody's always stealing credit.
Are we set up as a Hollywood thing until
you get into a relationship and it's,
everybody's fucking sits there. Oh,
now I'm laying down. There you go.
Now the back's better. Now.
The fucking back's better.
I don't even want to talk about,
um,
to anybody wants a formula
one race from Sochi in, uh,
in Russia. It's such a
weird name. So cheap.
That sounds like a more like a,
like a Chinese or Japanese.
Vietnamese. So cheap.
That does not sound
like Russian dark evil.
[inaudible] so ci,
that sounds too happy to be Russian,
but I have to tell you it was a fucking,
that's a what? A gorgeous city that
is. Huh? You know what I mean? I mean,
Russia scares the shit out of me.
I grew up during the end of the Cold War,
so I just figured you're going
to go over there and the second,
if you have any sort of a, I dunno,
American Shit on, it's just, you know,
I remember being in Finland being in
this cap and it blew my mind how close I
was to Russia. It's like, well I
can't believe I'm this, you know,
Far East into Europe.
And I asked the guy if he'd ever been
there and he started telling me about
Moscow. It was, you know, a little
dangerous after five, you know,
and I'm deciding, I just did the math
in my head. It's like, all right,
this guy's saying it's a little dangerous.
Finland beat Russia,
Finland defeated fucking
style. Okay. Style.
And whose those fucking people ran
over the Goddamn Nazi army with their
Mercedes Benz fucking tanks.
Right?
The portion jeeps,
I can't name one fucking Russian car.
All right. Just the sheer will
and toughness of those people,
you know? Yeah. We read those
stories and them fucking,
they're running around in their socks
in the middle of a Russian winter just
running the fucking German army.
Right back to Jeremy. You know?
Or where else would the German
people go back to? Well,
I could have retreated back to Poland.
God knows they fucking took that over,
right?
Yeah.
So I'm thinking,
you know,
okay,
take a beat. These guys,
Jesus Christ. What,
how the fuck would they lose to Finland?
You know,
that's the championship match right there.
That's Cleveland versus the warriors.
Finland. I mean, I was looking
at them like, all right,
that's the fucking warriors verse.
I Dunno the Phoenix Suns,
but the,
uh,
okay.
I Dunno, they fucking be
the fucking kick their ass.
But what sucked for them was at the
end of the war when Germany lost,
Italy fell and all that shit,
when the axis powers loss,
they were on the wrong side of the fucking
table. So they went down with them.
It was like a co op,
you know what I mean?
Like if you pay off your shares in
the building, you're like, all right,
I own my apartment. It's like, no you
don't. You won't shares in this building.
But if everybody else goes belly up,
the whole fucking thing is done
and then you lose your shares.
You have to go back to renting your
apartment or you have to fucking leave.
That's what it was like.
And that's what happened to them.
They paid off their shares in the
building in Italy and Germany went fucking
bankrupt. And uh, next thing you know,
that was it. And they had the giveaways,
like the southern part of their fucking
country or some shit there to give away.
Basically the stadium in which they won
the game, they had to give that to them.
I'm pretty sure that's what the fuck
happened. So when he was subsequently go,
and this is the,
this is the DNA that this guy comes from
and he's telling me that after five it
gets a little fucking scary. These
are the people that fucking, you know,
looked old, Yosef Stalin in
the fucking ice, you know,
fucking kicked his ass. He be like
around fucking cross country skis,
cross country ski CPT sons of
bitches and this guy's nervous.
So it's just like wow, it's gotta
be a scary fucking place over there.
And then I'm watching the f
one race on some ci right.
And it was fucking beautiful.
It looked like a Ron Howard film
starring Tom Hanks. You know,
you had a beautiful city
in the background. You had,
you went into a forest and
you had mountains, a little
snow caps on top of it.
It looked like a postcard. Like when
they take a postcard of Los Angeles,
you know,
like once a year it's clear enough
where you could take a picture of the
downtown La Skyline and then see snow
capped mountains in the background.
Right. Cause they always
say that, you know,
you can snowboard in the morning
and be surfing in the afternoon.
And if you're in La, you're looking around
going, where the fucking you snowboard.
It's cause you can't see, he can see
through all the fucking pollution. Um,
so anyway, so I'm watching this
goddamn race from Sochi, right?
Okay.
And um,
I got to tell you,
F one f one figured it out so far.
Four races in another
really exciting race.
Okay.
I don't know what happened.
They made the tires 30% bigger and all
of a sudden there's more fucking grip.
The Dad would force all this shit that
they talk about and it before every
frigging race,
I don't know what happened,
but all I know and friary made better
cars. Now all of a sudden it's a,
at least she got two teams race and Ford
is supposed to last year or was just a
Nico and, uh, Lewis Hamilton.
So anyways, congratulations. I
hope I say, speaking of Finland,
oh by say this guy's name, right?
Mercedes Benz, a tier two driver,
the upstart, the Tom Cruise
and days of thunder, right? Uh,
vault Valtteri bolt us.
I hope I said that right.
And he's like one of like nine
finished drivers to everyone.
A Formula One race. It congratulations
him drove great race. Uh,
Sebastian Vettel from Ferrari,
second place,
Kimi Raikkonen broken in
Sydney is raking in Kimmy.
So Cheeky Kimmy,
Kimchi,
Kimmy Reagan and for Ferrari came in
third and then Lewis Hamilton came and
forth. I can tell you right now, he
wasn't happy. You know, he wasn't happy.
That guy doesn't give a fuck if his
car doesn't work. He doesn't get,
he'll fucking run his own
teammate off the fucking track.
That's what I,
a little I know about that race.
All I know is if he's not
winning and his teammate can,
when he doesn't give a fuck, he's
not getting out of the way. You know,
he just doesn't give a shit.
Um, but then he also wins.
So whatever. Uh, so I guess that puts, uh,
the fuck's his name.
I was fucking up.
Sebastian Vettel isn't
first place he's got,
I think he's got two wins and two
second places. So you get 25, 25,
18 and 18.
So that's 50 and 3,686 points.
And I think, uh, you know,
I'm in the garage, dude.
I don't know the fucking
internet as far as I remember.
I think Lewis Hamilton has one victory,
two second places and a fourth.
Okay.
So that's 25,
18 and 18.
Oh Jesus Christ was at 61 36 and 25 slash
61 I'm going to say at 61 and he's got
a fourth place. When you give for
fourth place, like 15. I don't know.
He's got like, I dunno, we'll say
76 some shit. I don't fucking know.
All I know is it shaping up to be a
great year and for whatever reason,
even though I have German blood in
me, uh, no Italian blood. I actually,
I'm rooting for the fryer.
It's just because last year was it got
boring Mercedes one every fucking race.
So it's good to see Ferrari
back. Um, and by, by the way,
shout out to force India.
Yeah,
I think they came in eighth and ninth.
I was sixth and seventh.
My fault for having the balls.
They have pink cars out there or Fuchsia,
whatever you want to call them.
Okay.
You know, they'd been Mike, my uh,
my other team like I want to see
one of them win a race this year.
I want to see a pink
car when a fucking race.
It's just funny to me.
So anyways,
I don't know where the next race is.
I would look it up.
Usually if I'm not fucking laying on
the floor of my God damned garage,
I would know where the next uh,
the next race was.
I know there's probably a
lot of you going like, Bill,
what the fuck you getting into his,
first of all, it's a great fucking sport.
Second of law, it doesn't take a lot
of time to watch. There was 52 laps.
It's it, you can very
easily add debt, you know,
to whatever sports you watch.
And I'm telling you even during
the NBA and the NHL playoffs,
cause I fucking watched everything.
You know,
I watched the Saint Louis
Blues right this weekend.
Watch them win and over time
game to believe it was game two.
I watch so much shit this weekend
I watched, uh, the last two games,
Anaheim versus Edmonton.
Um,
amazing to see Edmonton like all of
a sudden looking like, wait a minute,
these guys are going to be the
western conference champions,
the way they are applying and all of
a sudden they get the old right there.
Fred from the fucking ducks in Edmonton,
one of those weird series where the three
games in and the home team has yet to
win a lot of children going home
crying during that series so far.
And um, I hate to say this is a
Bruins fan, but fucking Lou Cheech,
he looks right in that
uniform and I got to feel,
and he's going to stay there for awhile.
I don't know what kind of contract he's,
I don't know, signed up
there, but um, Jesus Christ,
he's looking like the old blue cheese
just to fucking force in nature.
I remember he would like fucking bring
it over the Blue Line and he sorta had
control of it,
but he didn't.
And he sort of just be kicking it in
and she wants somebody else's trying to
like fucking stop them. You just
give him a little fucking forearm.
The guy would fall down, he'd pass it
over version running score out. And she's,
I miss those days. Anyways.
Uh, but watching that,
of course I watched the
Celtics fucking wizards.
Ah,
the old sports rivalry that most of
the sports world does not realize is a
fucking rivalry.
These two teams hate each other,
but you know the deal, it's all about
the fucking golden state warriors.
It's all about the Cleveland
Cavaliers. And, um,
so no one's really paying attention,
right?
No one's paying attention to these two
fucking people. They know. It'd be like,
you know, you've got the rolling stones
and the Beatles and everybody says,
oh my God, they're fucking
amazing. And then meanwhile,
Herman in the hermit's doesn't get
along with the fucking partridge family.
I don't think we're that bad.
I'd like to think that we're not that
bad. But, um, anyways, so the first,
like if to give you a little bit of a
background for whatever stupid reason,
earlier this season,
the wizards were like,
we're going to dress all in black when
we play you guys, cause it's going to be,
it's going to be like a
funeral. And I was like, Oh,
J g h is that what you're going to do?
And then what are we going to do now?
Try,
are you going to try extra,
not extra hard tonight?
Fucking wizards,
right?
So even with that stupid
little fashion that they made,
they still beat us. So, but
not because they were black.
They beat us because they
scored more points. So anyways,
so we're getting ready to go see them.
Uh, we're getting ready to play them.
And um,
my buddy Josh,
Adam Meyers from the goddamn
comedy jam and from the comedy jam,
they had to clean it
up on a comedy central.
We decided that we're going to go down
to a cigar bar and we're going to watch
the fucking game together. He's a
big wizards fan and a, and he's a,
she's a Shit Talker, right? So
He's been talking shit, you know,
cause I think they won the,
uh,
I think we beat them like once
and they beat us like three times.
I can't even remember.
And he was talking all this shit and at
one point they were ahead of us in like
the rankings. They were number two, we
went up a three or something like that.
He was just talking all
of this fucking shit.
So the game starts to Goldbar
bar doesn't open till 11 games.
It comes on at 10.
So I'm sitting there watching the
fucking first quarter they go up to,
to nothing. Dennis, five to nothing.
Seven and nothing. Nine to nothing.
Fucking 12 to 16 and nothing
in case you missed the game,
you don't have fucking sports center
or whatever. 16 to fucking nothing.
Yeah.
To start the game, the game, it's over.
If it's any sort of illegitimates
I will legitimate sport.
This game is over and I gotta be,
I gotta be honest with you.
I will never like 100% be able to believe
that that basketball is not fixed.
Okay.
I don't understand it.
I don't understand how one team
can spot another team's 16 points.
You end the first quarter one teams on
pace to score 120 points or some shit.
And the other teams on pace to score
20 Ah, like 75 or some shit. Right.
Or whatever. 80 points or something.
And some I just, it's always,
it's a gable runs.
Then out of nowhere they started like
16 to nothing and then we go on like a
fucking 25 to eight runs and
somehow the score's tied. Oh,
we're up by like two what the
half? I don't know. I went,
I drove to pick him up and then
we went over to the cigar bar.
So there's a lot of Chit chat going on
and by the end of the third quarter we
were up by 15
okay.
We were down 16 nothing.
36 minutes of basketball later were up
by 15 a 31 point fucking turnaround.
Okay,
thank you man. When the bills came
back against the Houston Oilers,
this basically that,
that happens just about
every other game in the NBA.
I don't fucking get it. Well, it's
a game of runs. It's a game. Is it?
How does one team come out? Ice fucking
cold. The other team can't miss.
And then like,
okay,
like I've never had a set where I go on
stage and it's just like I'm on and then
all of a sudden I'm off and then
I'm on again and then I'm off.
That's what happens.
Basketball.
So we're up by 50 Josh is
losing his fucking mind.
He standing up,
he's pacing,
which is hilarious because it's a cigar
bar is supposed to be like totally
Chili's fucking pacing back and forth.
He's slamming down
fucking slices of pizza,
you know like doing like stress
eating and I'm just laughing.
I was just going like Josh, it's the
fucking NBA. This game's going to be like,
now we're going to do the fourth quarter.
And because the third quarter ended,
the switch gets shut off and the other
one gets flipped on and do what is going
to be at fucking tie game. So what
happens? Fourth quarter starts,
the fucking Celtics can't score a
bucket for like the first four minutes.
And next thing you know,
like the wizard to down by three and Josh
Joshua sitting down again and I'm just
laughing. It's like, how many fucking
NBA Games do you have to watch?
Which you really do if you just want it,
if you really get into the games and you
feel like you're going to fucking die a
thousand deaths, what you should really
do is just watched the last two minutes.
God knows that takes as much time
as the first fucking 46 minutes.
Just watched the last two minutes because
it's going to be like a fucking three
point game anyways. And, um,
whatever the ebb and flow and then some
other Celtics pulled away again. But, uh,
I gotta tell you it's going to be a
fucking brutal series [inaudible] series.
And I think a Jae Crowder might
get kicked out for one game.
This can be some sort
of physical altercation.
I don't know what's going to happen,
but looking into my fucking crystal ball,
I don't know who it's going to be,
but somebody's going to get
fucking kicked out of the game. Uh,
get suspended for a game because he's
fucking teams hate each other. And, um,
you already started to see it happen a
little bit in the first game. I just,
they just don't like each other,
but I gotta tell you some,
I actually love that John Wall
guy. I loved one, uh, uh, Josh,
show me this fucking,
uh,
whatever the fuck Instagram
picture or something like that.
It gets a couple of years ago,
they lost to the, uh, Atlanta, um,
the fuck are they? The hawks, the
Atlanta Hawks. Yeah. Saint Louis Hawks,
the Atlanta Hawks, right? They lose
two. And one of the guys on Atlanta,
you know, they had a picture of them.
Then the final seconds of winning
and John Wall has a real sad look on his
face to do the posts of it's real happy.
And then there's another Lana Hawk
looking at John Wall laughing at him. And,
uh, I guess John Walden, forget about
this. So when they beat Atlanta,
he posted a picture of him,
you know,
doing a crossover in the gout posted
the picture fell on his fucking ass.
I love people that hold grudges like that.
I think that to be great,
you have to be like that, which is why
Eli Manning is such a fucking enigma.
You know what I mean? I swear to God,
like if you saw that guy in the most
in the final two,
two minute office of a Superbowl,
his heart rate is the same is somebody
at a fucking bake sale right outside of
church.
You know what I mean?
Oh he thanks for coming out or
how big your kids are getting.
That's where his heart rate is.
You know,
I swear to God they should just see it.
All those dockers he's always wearing
with the fucking sweater tucked into them.
They should just make a uniform just
to completely psych out the other team.
If I was the giant side, he'd have like
a special pair of football pants. They'd,
they'd be the same colors. Dockers.
He'd still have the pads and shit in it.
But you know,
some sort of dad jeans.
So anyways, I think the Celtics
was just going to go, uh,
I think that's going to go seven and I
think it's going to be fucking brutal.
I think, uh, the wizards when the next
one, and then I think we split down in DC,
I think it's just going to go back and
forth, back and forth, back and forth. Um,
did that evenly matched and um, I
dunno. I always forget the guy's name.
That fucking Polish Transylvanian Dude,
the white dude with a shaved
head whose entire body is,
is fucking hard as the top
of his goddamn head. I mean,
that guy looks like he could have
played like fucking professionally,
could have played like at
least three different sports.
Fucking played spin, some gigantic
fucking tight end. You know,
he's there. His body, he's like
fucking White Lebron. I know, I know.
I've gone on a limb there, but I'm telling
you that guy, he's a fucking beast.
Who's joker with Josh coming?
His Dad fucking grew up in eastern Europe.
His Dad probably fucking beat him with
one of those fireplace. Pokers all right.
We're all laughing. I was sitting there
going like that. That can't be the name.
Okay. There's gotta be a different
name for the four fire fireplace poker.
I'm just saying what it
does that can't be the name.
And I looked it up and that's
exactly what it's called.
Okay.
Fireplace poker.
That's the best they could come up with.
They couldn't come up with some widget
name, you know, even with like the ladies,
they got that thing they put in their
hair. Somebody came up. What's it called?
That has called a Flowbee.
Oh, what? Yeah. A Flowbee.
The fuck is a Flowbee. I had
something. You sticking your hair,
it makes it to a couple of woopty dues.
I don't know what I'm talking about.
Let me do, um, let me, uh,
let me read a little advertising here
and then I'll talk about what a sad time
it is to be a Washington DC
fucking sports fan. Jesus Christ.
All the fucking crying
these Cleveland fans did.
Did you ever see a city cry as much as
say did? Oh, we show funky, miserable.
I mean, maybe they did that in
Boston back when we weren't,
weren't fucking winning, but I always
hated that shit over a long time ago.
Espn did this whole,
they wouldn't have some trial.
Like who has the more
miserable fucking sports fans?
Cubs fans are red sox fans. I remember
sitting at home laughing going, dude,
I don't know. I don't know
when this, you want to be more.
Who the fuck wants to
be the most miserable?
MMM.
You know who those fucking the kind of
person you don't want to run into in a
goddamn bar.
You know?
Could you sit there and just talk about
how life fucked him over? Sorry. Anyways,
let me them read some of the, some
of this advertising here. Oh my God.
It's that time.
It's that time of year when you can say,
I got to get something for my mother
pro flowers.
Everybody talk about how
being a mom is often,
often a thankless job and mother's Day
is a chance to show your appreciation.
Um, I think that's talked about enough,
isn't it? It's always, you know,
I want to see if they have
that copy for father's day,
that it's a fucking thankless job when
we taste something right now. All right.
Is is difficult a job is being a mother
is you fucking babies are obsessed with
you. My daughter barely looks at me. She
just looked at me, she smiles like, Hey,
there's that guy that I kind of know,
but my wife walks in the room,
she just like, she just follows her all
around. Just is looking at it. I'm like,
hey other parent or the parent over
here, Yo, Yo. You know what I mean?
You know like when you're at the,
at the game and they're thrown free
tee shirts into the crowd, right.
And you standing up and then there's a
group of fucking hoe like hot chicks and
shit. Like, like you're getting the
tee shirt. It doesn't stop you though.
You still stand up fucking flailing.
Your arms never happens.
Um, so evidently for some reason
being a mom is a thankless job.
Even though everybody always talks
about how important the job is.
There's not one presidential election
that doesn't go by where they don't talk
about it. Everybody's
always saying, you know,
mothers are saints and all of
this type of shit. You know,
what do they say about that?
They say nothing.
It's like put both on the same record
label, but only their album gets height.
You know, when our fucking do
nothing, managers go and like, yeah,
you promised us at least one billboard.
Okay,
Easter fucking vine. You know,
you can't even give us that. Um,
but evidently I have to do it
again. Oh, Jesus. You know,
Keith just can't fucking
thank these divas enough.
These mothers out there. Is there anything
worse than when you listen to a woman?
Say she lost herself in the relationship.
You know, and then you find that,
you know, it's one thing if you just,
you know, if you don't have kids,
but if a woman says that and they
have kids right there, you know what?
Terrible mother,
she deserves no flowers.
But the rest of you ladies listen to this.
When you send the 100 blooms
for mom, both bouquet, bouquet,
whatever from pro flowers,
this mother's Day,
you will make a real impression. Oh yeah.
Now your mother's going to love you.
It looks down their work in the sibling
rivalry into this. He's fucking,
people have no shame over that.
Pro Flowers,
it comes with a free glass vase for just
1999 piece of shit plus shipping and
handling. And if you really
want to make a statement,
you can upgrade a premium to a premium
vase and include gourmet chocolates for
just $10 more gourmet
chocolates for 10 bucks. Okay.
Uh,
choose to deliver it.
You want to buy this f one car for fucking
$11 is this the wheel of fortune back
in the day for $26,
they'll take the bed frayed.
I'll take the cuckoo clock for 18.
I'll put the rest on a gift certificate.
You know what a year supply of trident
gum choose the delivery date you want and
pro flowers are guaranteed to arrive fresh
and beautiful and stayed that way for
at least seven days or your money back.
The only way to get 100 blooms
for mom with a free glass vase
starting@nineteenninetynineistovisitproflowers.com
click
on the
microphone
did
right at the top right
corner and use my code burr.
That's proflowers.com and code bird.
When you click on the mic,
this studying bouquet bouquet
sells out fast. So order today,
this is a great deal
of what this thing is.
They act like this is the one thing
you need to get your mom. It isn't.
This is like at least the
thing you got to get few mom,
this is a great [inaudible] to something
else. Um, I do it every single year.
It's nice and fucking easy. And you
know what? Your mother loves flowers.
You know why? Because moms
are dreamers. They believe.
They believe that their husband's
not going to come home hammered.
This is the time Angela's ashes.
He's not going right to the pub.
He's finally going to take my kid to the
doctor and figure out what that fucking
eye infection is. You guys ever read
that book? Angela's ashes. Jesus Christ.
You know, you thought Charlie Brown
had a bad trying to kick the football.
Fucking poor bastards went for
their dad to come up with the money.
Never came on. Went to
the ghost. You know,
spoiler alert goes to the
pub every fucking time.
All right.
Sherry's berries.
Everybody talk about a mom
you really admire and why?
Well,
wouldn't that be my mom?
I'll tell you as much as I love
my mom is a mob down the street.
She just has those intangibles.
Mother's Day is coming
up and Sherry's berries.
Was that like some politically correct
thing? Like talk about your mom. Well,
what about what if the podcast Ma mom's
dead? What about that? We want to,
we'll fucking avoid that shit.
Mother's Day's coming.
Everybody and Sherry's be
Aries is offering huge,
freshly dipped strawberries starting at
1999 plus shipping and right now you can
double the berries for $10 more.
Pick your delivery date and these berries
are guaranteed to arrive fresh and
delicious or your money back.
You may think you've seen gourmet dip
strawberries before. You know what?
I got to tell you,
there's a lot of things I think during
the day and that was not one of them.
I don't even know what they look like.
I don't even understand why they taste
so good. We'll go fuck. Figure that out.
God bless the person that did cause.
These things are delicious.
I will tell you that. Um, but you had,
but you've never seen anything like these.
Sherry's berries are huge, sweet, juicy,
and covered in decking and topics.
Chocolate chips,
chopped nuts,
white milk and dark chocolaty,
goodness Jesus.
This is getting gross.
Sherry's berries or an unexpected gift
that will put a smile on mom's face.
Holy Shit. Did you drop 20 bucks on
me? That was unexpected surprise.
The mom in your life was Sherry's
berries, interoffice. Slash. Workplace.
You can't send chocolate covered
strawberries to your mom at work.
Everybody's going to think
she's having an affair.
The only way to get this
amazing Barry's deal
starting@justnineteenninetynineistovisitberries.com.
Click on the microphone at the top
right corner and use my code burr.
That's Barry's, B. E r r I e. s.com Bravo,
echo, Romeo, Romeo, India,
Echo sierra.com and my code burr.
When you click on the mic,
this amazing deal,
it won't last long and mother's Day
is right around the fucking corner,
so be sure to order now. I believe it's
like May 14th this year. So if I was you,
I would just knock this out right now
and then wander into a mall and find
something else that you could get her.
You know what I mean?
A fucking Dutch oven or some shit.
What does she do? Does she cook?
Okay.
The people even go to malls anymore.
Oh, you just go to amazon.com I have to
go into my fucking website going to the
podcast page and clicking on the
Amazon link so I get a little doe.
Ray me set my way. Sorry. All right,
here we go. Oh, look what's here.
[inaudible] Mia.
Andy's getting ready for mother's
Day Badu due to Mandy's Mia.
Andy's drop your drawers
and she'll say, hey, Yay.
Cup your velvety underwear drawers.
Stop shaking your ass.
They'll think you're a male horse when
you put on your Randy's for mother's Day.
I don't know why I'm singing
about my mom with me undies.
Baba Dabba Doo, Doo, Doo, a whatever. All
right, me. Andy's, everybody. Me undies.
Do you need a place to
stick your chocolate covered
fucking strawberries right
next to your own. Barry. Stay. You go and
then fucking uh, there you go. Come in.
Pelvic pumping on mother's Day and
see how she likes that. All right.
Why don't you do that this year?
Just fall on the fucking knife.
So every one of her other,
every one of your other siblings can
look like a great kid. All right.
Jesus Christ. Bill, how do you sell
underwear after that? Well, I dunno,
but we're going to try it.
All right.
Elevate your underwear game to
the next level with me on DC.
You've perfected your wardrobe,
but what about the stuff?
Not everybody gets to see if you've been
settling for store, bought underwear,
five packs.
If you've been settling for going to
those prepackaged priest sewn together
fucking underwears.
I have something that will change
your life for the better me undies.
What is me undies?
Oh be Andy's me undies.
Velvety fucking underwear.
But due to [inaudible] take your
balls out and everyone stares.
Looking at this as a 10 year anniversary,
you're getting two songs,
rob nuts up against the modal.
Okay.
Grab your dog by the fucking throat.
All throw it outside because it took a
shit right next to your underwear drawer.
I didn't go to jail for animal cruelty.
Alright me undies are designed in La.
Okay.
La,
Louisiana plus the Angeles.
Who knows and made from
sustainably sourced micro
modal bow down a fabric three
times softer than cotton.
Beyond these softer than soft luxury
under you come in an ever changing
selection of classic colors,
bold shades and adventurous patterns so
you can tailor your undies to your own
personal style. I think this is why
Richard Simmons actually disappeared once.
He could start ordering fucking velvety,
soft different underwear every
fucking day. You know what I mean?
He probably, he's like, well,
I can't wait these candy stripe fucking
shorts anymore. And that's my look.
You know what? I've made enough fucking
money about. All right, and guess what?
You can save time and money.
[inaudible] I've got a frog in my
throat all of a sudden. And guess what?
You could save time and money each
month with a monthly subscription.
And if you're not ready for a
scription but then go fuck yourself.
Stay with your regular goddamn under
way you piece of shit. No, I'm sorry.
That's a well that's not the copy. If
you, I'm sorry. If you're not ready,
that's okay.
Completely different direction.
You can still say that's because me
undies is offering you 20% off your first
pair.
Just use our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash bar and
get 20% off your first fucking pair.
So go ahead, revamp your underwear drawer.
You deserve it. Once again, that's me.
undies.com/ [inaudible] [inaudible] dot
com slash bird beyond these me undies.
Really revamping your underwear drawer
Badu too to me. Undies me undies.
Get some fruity panties. You whore. They
may come for the ladies for their twats.
If you don't have, ah shit, it fell apart.
stamps.com everybody.
I, you know something.
I use stamps.com whenever I'm fucking
sending Mike a fresh pair of me undies out
to Cleveland Hilarides who are, I'm
going to be this Tuesday and Wednesday.
Um, I use me on these whenever I'm pouring
myself out selling posters and I'm a
moron if I can figure out how
to use that little device.
God knows you can't stamp
saved you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business,
right?
Okay,
well do whatever you want.
You know,
what's your favorite clip from fucking
a stroke, race? Whatever you want to do.
I can mail any letter,
any package.
She was suggested my computer and printer
and the mailman comes and picks it up.
Unlike the post office.
stamps.com never closes right under,
like unlike that fucking
whore you used to do
date.
Okay.
No, I'm saying this wrong
with Sarah legs. Never close.
Unlike that prude.
I just, just going off the
risk. stamps.com never closes.
Print postage letters or packages
at your convenience. 24, seven,
seven days a week. Convenient,
easy, reliable, flexible.
No need to, no need to lease. An
expensive postage meter right now.
You can enjoy the stamps service,
what they special offer.
That includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale without any
long term commitments. Jesus Christ.
God has stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbernthatstampsdotcomenterbarstamps.com
never go to the post office again.
There you go.
You like that person that graduated
high school and never came back to their
hometown and for some reason thinks that
they're a success because they didn't.
You know, you don't, it makes you a
success not leaving your hometown.
It's how you treat people and you
know something that's one to grow on.
All right, before I get into the
questions here, let's talk about uh,
the Washington sad sack. Washington
DC sports fan. You know what I mean?
After all this fucking shit
about cubs fans, red sox fans,
fans of Cleveland Sports.
Meanwhile,
look at fucking Washington DC.
They have nothing nationals.
They went and Shit.
The Redskins have been a fucking joke,
a fucking joke for 25 fucking years.
I know what you think will build.
They want three fucking super bowls in
the previous basically 10 11 years. Yeah,
but you know something.
They got some racist logo on the side.
There was always something to take
it away. You know what I mean?
Where does thing ever,
they had some black guy dressed up on
the fucking native American head dress,
maybe had some Indian blood in him. I
have no idea. Native American blood.
Whenever the fuck you supposed to say,
you know the capital's how many times
they go with the president's trophy get
bounced out in the second round.
They've won the case.
They won the president's trophy three
times since 2009 and every time they'd
lost in the second round and they've
dropped the first two fucking games and I
was watching the end of this series at
home against the Pittsburgh Penguins,
the reptilian ice water in their veins.
Pittsburgh penguins who
I'm telling you right now.
I'll go in on and they're going to
win this second Stanley Cup in a row.
You heard it here.
You heard it.
Now you play it later and you will agree
with me or you don't have a combatant
fucking podcast again. No gift. Now
I think they're just going to repeat.
That's what it is. They're all
dialed in. They got Phil Kessel,
they got Crosby.
They get so fucking day,
got a fucking mock Andriy flour,
whatever his fucking name
is Theo fucking flurry,
whatever the goaltenders name is,
he doesn't give a shit.
He's out there fucking doing the old
fucking jazz hands stop and everything
that's coming right mark on brief flurry,
they got Jido this.
They're just gonna overpower you.
It's it.
Or does Washington DC with the Capitol
state rise up from the ashes in somehow
figure out
a fucking way to win. Game three.
I was watching the NHL network.
This guy was going off going,
this is the biggest fucking game in
Washington capitols history and I agree.
They got to do this. They got to
this, and if they don't do this,
they're going to blow up the whole
fucking team. It's going to be sad.
They don't have to start all over again.
Okay,
Jesus Christ. How do you not root
for the capitals and game three?
You got to do it.
I'm going to be rooting for,
yeah
dude. Sidney Crosby. I tell
I've been saying this for you.
Sidney Crosby's backhand
as more fucking velocity.
They're most guys for his most guys wrist
is in the league. It's fucking insane.
Thank God you know something. God blessed
his mother for raising him. Right?
Cause I'll tell you right
now with his backhand,
thank God he knows how to treat a woman.
Cause if he didn't Jesus Christ,
he would make Oj looked like a
fucking cub scout. All right,
so game three is coming up.
Definitely check that out.
And a,
and with that,
here's some of the people's favorite
Monday morning podcast moments.
MMP Bowman's,
that's what Andrew wrote.
Oh we should have like the little
big eyed smiling kids here. Um,
Douche bag of the week.
Brad, remember that? Um,
don't care enough to find the link.
But when Nia gave white people credit
for creating the jug instrument,
it was incredible. Uh, that was funny.
Oh then the classic member granny
fucking water it poor best.
It's probably still getting weird looks
for those of you don't know a granny
water was,
this guy was playing some fucking game.
It's kind of seemed like it was old maid,
but a,
you didn't want to like if you
played the grantee water card,
you fucked everybody else in the game.
So it came as time to play it.
And he's with his girlfriend and they're
playing with the parents and out of
nowhere,
for whatever reason,
he decides to give him the Monday
morning podcast answer on the f word.
And when he played the car,
he just went granny fucking war
and there was just dead silence.
Okay.
And then he tried, tried to have to sit
there and explain it to everybody. Uh,
the, it's granny fucking water listener
story from last year, I think. Uh,
another one,
greedy fucking water.
The infamous Rosebowl story had me in
stitches at work. That was the time when,
uh,
we got to put together a greatest hits.
We really got to do that. That was
the first rose bowl that we went to.
Yeah.
When we stumbled in there and
I fucking lost my balance.
And there was an old woman in front of
me and I had to like at my forum was in
her back and she was kind of leaning
forward and I was just sitting here going,
oh, shy, sorry.
And no one helped me up cause he was
so horrified by the condition I was in.
The only way for me to get up was I had
to push off of her folded or and half.
Oh God. I always get this weird feeling
in my stomach whenever I don't have a,
I hate that I did that,
but I did.
Yeah,
I apologize. Whoever his grandmother
that, but I made whatever. She's
a little more flexible, you know,
she'll enjoy the last, you know,
third of her life maybe.
Um,
not the person rose bowl
story with Joe Barden. Nick,
the old lady who kept getting angry and
calling. Her husband had threatened you,
mark. No, she wasn't an old lady.
She was younger and that was the time
she made fun and she made fun to Joe
Barton. Nick's nose. Janie had a big
nose and he just looked at her and said,
you need to lose about 30 pounds
before you talk to me, bitch.
And I was just like, Oh God, all
right, we're getting kicked out.
And then she said, she's like, mark,
did you hear what he said? Right.
So the guy turns around
to square off with Bartok.
Bartok just looks at him and he used his
big as a fucking Pittsburgh linebacker.
So the guy takes one look at Bart,
nick,
and then starts fucking yelling at me
and started threatening to throw me down
on the field. Uh, you fucking pussy. Yeah,
you go right past Barton and can you
go to old fucking bald carrot top.
All right. I'm a new listener.
He's a his his favorite moment.
You asking Nia how she's so loud wearing
slippers and she saying that's why
she's angry with you. That's love. There
you go. Um, all right, another one.
You answered a question about a parrot
like three years ago that it had me
crying, laughing at my job. I got
in trouble. I'll try to find it.
I love how vague these are. This is just
as vague. Um, oh, this person like the,
for me,
I just feel the Kardashians.
The Kardashians could literally watch a
baby starve to death and then then they
would be crying, you know, fanning.
They're fucking eyeliner so it doesn't,
you know, smear going. Like for me,
I just felt so sad because for me,
um,
it has to be that or the Colby 11th.
Oh God.
Kelly Olynyk and those fucking Colby
11th is the worst thing I ever saw.
A when you said Corey Feldman was
the Lee Harvey Oswald of the robot,
I had to pull over. I was
laughing so hard. I don't even,
it doesn't even make sense
to me anymore. Um, anyways,
let's see. Don't blow it. Keep
it simple. Count your money.
I don't even know what that is. Uh,
when you did the ad for draft kings,
one guy won $1,000.
One guy's giving hand jobs for rent
money or something like that. Oh yeah,
that's right. I called that thing out
for fucking being legalized gambling.
Um, what else? TC?
Come on. Frogs, dude. I
called it barefoot pitches.
There's too many to remember. I'm still
working my way through the older ones,
so this is really making me feel good
that you guys remember all this shit.
All right,
here's another one.
One of the best moments was when you
told the story of going to the basketball
game and they kept playing
that everybody clap your hands.
That's right. And it was all that crazy
shit going on. Oh, everybody loves this.
Read Old Zip,
uh, nature's box. Yeah,
I fucked that one up.
I called. It was,
it was nature box was the name of it
and I thought it was like possessive
nature's box and I was like, you going
down on Mother Nature? Needless to say,
that was one and done
read and full refund.
Okay.
Um,
some point we should put,
I want to put together all the fucking
one and done reads that I've had, um,
under the clip. Didn't make a dime
off those cans. All right. Um, oh,
the Monday morning podcasts. Nia, did you,
Maria, did you hear about Paula Abdul?
She was like,
I was like,
she's a former backup dancer for
the Lakers and now a big pop star.
She thought she died. I did it
better the first time. Anyways. Uh,
when you told Nia about not checking
out the funniest thing ever?
Oh yeah. When I don't check out at
hotels, um, I just walk out. I'm done.
Done with you fucking people.
Uh,
when you compared Harry Truman
to the guy from Shawshank,
am I being obtuse or your last
draft? Kings read. All right.
The Charlie Murphy one. No.
Yeah. Yeah. That was, uh,
that was a sad one. But it happy,
happy memories. Uh, the Yoko Ono rant,
strawberry poops. That's from the, uh,
the Joe Rogan on it and read a,
anytime you talk about cool cars,
anytime you lean away from the mic
and Yell Lane, uh, we're all humans.
Some of us are good. Most of us are
cons. Oh, the big tears. Big Tears.
When Nia cried and, um, where
were we? Italy. And I didn't
know how to comfort her.
I just kept going.
I was hugging her and she was crying.
She had like the biggest
tears coming out of her eyes,
like just fallen on my hands,
like raindrops. I was like
hugging him from behind,
you know, she, she hit her head.
That's why she bent down to pick something
up and there was a shelf and she hit
her head so fucking hard. My, my either my
eyes like, just watered like, Holy Shit.
I didn't know how to comfort
us. So she was crying. It just,
I just started reporting. But what
was going on? I was just going, ah,
that's just going big chairs.
All right. As a stoner, I find
your Auntie, we'd rans hilarious.
I get so mad that I started
hyperventilating. The lovely Nia,
everybody eggs and not an, it's
not me. It's near like Nancy,
uh, Nia story about hitting her head
in her big tears. Big Tears. All right.
We said that one. Okay. Uh,
you said ric flair wouldn't
have come up that fast.
I don't even know what that is. Colby 11.
Why are you going to Indianapolis bail?
Oh,
that fucking freak from the plane.
MMM.
Let me see.
Friends trying to get the rat out of
your new house story is an all time
favorite. Anytime there's a zip all
yeah. When we were renting that house,
when I got the fucking kitchen redundant,
um,
MMM
fucking zillion dollars I put in this
house, I'm never going to get back. Uh,
the one time you were talking about
those two guys eating shit or riding the
skateboard
and motorcycle,
the skateboard or crashing is the funniest
story you've ever told that needs to
be an animal. Oh my God. They, we
should animate. That is so right.
At time I saw that fucking Guy Griffith
park coming down and he wasn't dressed
like a skateboarder and it was like
seven 30 in the morning. You know,
when I was walking my old dog
Cleo, oh, I miss that dog.
I'm going to see her again next month.
I just feel it like she's in college
and I still always got a visitor. Look,
I love that dog and I'm fucking going
to be there someday when she takes her
final breaths, I'm going to fucking
be there. Um, anyways. Yeah.
So I was walking my dog and this fucking
guy came by like the biggest hill in
Griffith park and he was just dressed in
street clothes and it started wobbling
all my God, a new fucking
reference here, like in a moto GP,
the tank slap when it starts
fucking oscillate and you know,
and all of a sudden they
can't get it to stop.
He started doing that shit and just like,
I don't know,
I'll try and find the clip because
I was more vivid when I just saw it.
It was one of the fucking
most insane wipeouts.
It easily could have taken
over the agony of defeat, um,
in wide world of sports. Um, anyways. Um,
what else? How many six year olds could
you kill before they took you down?
You know, I was actually thinking
about animating that recently,
but after all the fucking psycho horrible
shit that's happened in the world
since I did that used to be
funny, you know, and that's
the world we're living in.
It's not funny anymore to me.
All right,
Doug Flutie heckling story about
a friend who takes things too far.
May Be cry laughing at the gym. No
idea which episode that was. Oh yeah.
That was a buddy of mine who
didn't know how to talk shit.
Okay,
I'll tell you that one quickly.
Uh,
Doug Sudi came back playing for the
bills and we're sitting in the end zone
seats and um,
everybody's like heckling Doug Flutie
gonyet killed image it. Hey Doug,
you two small blah blah, blah, blah, blah.
And my buddy wanted to get in and
all the shit talk and uh, you know,
go back to the CFL and everybody's just
trashing him and my buddy doesn't know
where the line is. And he also studied
starters and out of nowhere he just goes,
hey, hey, hey, hey Flutie.
I hope you kid dies in everybody in the
end zone who was hammered immediately
sobered up just when like, ah, and
everybody just sat shifts like, dude,
what the fuck?
Fucking brutal.
All right.
Which also used to kind of be amusing to
me until now I have a kid now I'm just
kind of like, yeah, that really, he wasn't
really funny either. Alright, Jason Marks.
I don't know what that one is.
Draftkings final read. And lastly,
but not leastly don't wear different.
No nowhere to find the link,
but the one that introduced the great
add Paul Versey where you guys debated
time travel. Oh, that was a good one.
That was a good one, man. All right,
let me read, I got time here
to read a couple of, uh,
a couple of questions here for
the week. All right. Military,
uh, their bill of the Boar Bu Oh, Ari,
I don't know what that means.
I will see you podcasts all the time.
I also from time to time, uh,
appreciate your standup comedy.
Oh,
that was a nice backhanded compliment.
I listened to your podcast all the
time and also from time to time,
appreciate your standup comedy. You
know, it's got a ride from time to time.
He makes me smile.
I am from New Hampshire and your video
tour of Hampton beach was right on the
money. I am writing to you about
my best bud in the military.
We are both in the service as
we became friends. He confessed,
he confessed that he's a virgin.
At the age of 32 over the past two years
since I've known the guy he refers to
play video games and eat
dunkaroos then going out in public.
Don't go rose.
What the fuck are those?
Um,
he's an exceptionally funny kid and has
no problem making good impression on
strangers or even a lady.
He just cannot reach women
in a sexual way right now.
He stationed in Europe in good shape,
has a bad ass jobs,
speaks French and is
generally charismatic guy.
He has every reason to be doubt drowning
and ladies and can even use the foreign
card.
But as I check in with them,
he still hasn't gotten out from
behind the 60 inch plasma TV.
I don't know what his problem is because
he would always be bitching about
wanting a girlfriend. I think he
may be whacking it too much. Uh,
the new echo epidemic.
And another tidbit is that he
will turn to heavy drinking,
which actually helps to open them up.
I can tell he's not satisfied being
sick single and using alcohol,
but will not take the
initiative to break the cycle.
I'm pissed because he's not using the
golden opportunity to slay over there and
he's just disrespecting and it's
just disrespectful to the rest of us.
That's fucking hilarious.
Um, yeah man, he seems,
I would say that he should probably go
to therapy and work out whatever it is
hang up is, because that could be
a lot of shit that he's sitting on
and um,
yeah, that's sad. I feel bad for that guy.
You know what I mean? It'd be one thing,
like some people just naturally like
the loners and asexual or whatever,
and they don't want to be out there,
but whatever his deal is, you know,
be a sad thing. If somebody wanted to
find love and they couldn't find love,
that guy should be crushing it.
If he could speak French and he can
speak English like that. France,
that's your whole
fucking world over there.
Even if you went to England and they
don't give a fuck that you could speak
English cause so today, but if you
go, so bust out some French, Bam,
you crushed in that.
Yes.
And he's a man in
uniform through this guy.
He's like fucking like three
different porno fantasies for women.
Yeah,
he's got what? What is he going
to do next? Start cleaning polls.
Delivering pizzas. Yeah. There's no reason
for it. I would tell you buddy that he,
she should go talk to somebody about it,
but it's kind of difficult
if he's drowning himself at
booze and a,
it's a delicate thing and
it's very difficult to get
somebody to go get help and
I mean they have to want to
do it themselves. So, um,
but you've got Fred met cause you get,
you actually give a shit. All right.
Conspiracy theory. Sorry,
I'm rushing through this.
I'm coming up on an hour
in these fucking gas line.
People are going to be shown up
soon. Conspiracy theory. Uh, Bill,
what do you think of the flat earthers
it's a growing movement of people who
think we're being lied to
about the shape of the earth.
Do you think this is something you would
have bought into in your earlier more
intense conspiracy days? No, I wouldn't.
You fucking cunt all you guys. This is
what I hate about conspiracy theory.
Conspiracy theory is everybody
gets lumped into the,
people think the moon is made out of
cheese and that they're shape shifters and
lizard people.
Okay.
All I was saying is that the fucking
Federal Reserve is a privately owned
corporation,
which is a fucking fact.
Okay.
I'll say things like,
I don't think that the government or
the corporations give a shit about the
people in Iraq because I saw the way
they treated these people in New Orleans.
They don't give a fuck about them.
They don't give a shit about those people
over there. Okay, so I don't buy that.
That's, that's the level that I go to.
All right. I don't take it to this.
This is what I would say to those
fucking flat earth people. Okay. Okay.
Let's just say the earth is flat then.
Wouldn't all the ocean waters
just run off the end of it?
Why isn't that happening?
How do you explain that?
I would love to talk to a flat earth
person, you know, and be like, well,
why don't you guys do a startup and
get yourself a little fucking rocket?
Go up in the fucking air. It's like,
have you ever Fuckin flown in a jet?
You Jackass, you can look
out the window and say, cl,
you'd see the roundness of the earth.
MMM.
I Dunno, but you know what? I want
to fucking watch videos of it.
I want to hear what they think flat
earthers are actually more ridiculous than
people trying to exclude
believe in like, uh, uh,
creationism or whatever.
Believe in Adam and Eve,
Adam and Eve to white people that somehow
created Asians and black people and
all that type of shit. I don't
fucking get all that. Well, actually,
you know something. Yeah, I dumped, you
know what I think I actually believe,
believe what that type of shit.
I actually think that a,
I watched one of those Neil degrasse
Tyson things and he said, you know,
we actually came out of trees
and I was just like, you know,
what is fucked up is that is at least
I can look at a tree. It'd be like,
there it is. That is a trait.
Can Walk over, I can touch it,
I can climb on it. Um, it actually
made more sense to me then. Um,
okay.
Then Adam and eve, I mean it's just,
I don't know if you put like Adam,
if Adam and eve was a movie and
then the tooth fairy was a movie,
I mean I'd put them in the exact same
category and I don't think that that's
right. All right. Conspiracy theory. Oh,
everywhere. I've already read that one.
India, taking cash out of
circulation. Oh, Jesus Christ.
Bill just read an article about India
and it freaked me out a little bit.
Last November, India removed 86% of
the country's cash from circulation.
Most people are now using mobile
payment options and the artists see,
I don't know what that means. Also
goes on to say the article, sorry,
I got the laptop on the
floor, but there was a TRC. I,
the article also goes on to say that ATM
machines at Bank cars would be obsolete
as early as 2020 in India.
Not having physical money and only using
a phone for buying stuff really makes
me uncomfortable. Any thoughts? Yet?
They're on their way to microchipping
all of us. And once again,
everybody's gonna think that's fucking
crazy. You can go on the Internet,
you can look at shitheads who work for
corporations that are like proud of their
fucking microchip and their level of
security clearance that they have. No,
they're going to phase
out fucking everything.
There's going to be cameras everywhere.
You're going to be fucking
microchipped and this is the thing,
it's still not going to be
enough control for them.
They still won't feel
comfortable that they had.
That's how bad their
fucking you over that.
They need to have that level
of fucking surveillance on you.
That's how fucking weird they are.
And they want to see what you talk about,
what you jerk off to and all this
shit that fits fucking beyond creepy.
And I hate when something like that gets
brought up on like the fucking news and
all in the best the news anchor could
do is kind of widen the eyes like okay,
that's kind of a,
that's going to be interesting.
And then they immediately go to talk
to us about some fucking old lady that,
you know, just, you know,
made her own jam or some shit.
That's the feelgood story to get out of
it. No, it's unbelievably fucking creepy.
And um, I dunno, I have
no idea how to stop it.
I have no idea how to, to fucking
stop it because no matter what you do,
people just sit there. Like,
I watched this thing on,
on the news and they showed
a robot talking to a little
five year old kid in the
robot was going like if
you put me in the closet,
that would make me sad.
And like the robot is preying on the
fucking emotions of a five year old kid.
Like that things should be illegal.
Okay.
Like, do you realize how
fucked up that I make us?
We've always done that with products,
preying on the emotions of kids,
but to just see it in that level of raw
form and just sit there and having this
robot lying to a five year old,
like it has fucking feelings. Um,
I don't know.
Does it mean it was everything seemed
like it's just really sped up the we're
just heading right over the fucking
waterfall. That's, that's what I thinks.
Gonna I dunno. That's what
I believe anyways. Um, I
actually, this is my theory.
I believe that there's the upper 1%
and that they are going to get us all
microchipped and when they
get sick of that shit there,
they're going to dig in a sick.
The robots on us,
they going to take us all out and it
eventually the robots will take over the
upper 1% and um, and not in the way you
think. They're not going to kill him.
They're just going to be like all
looking like supermodels and human beings
won't bang each other anymore
cause it's going to be,
it's to be way more difficult.
You know what I mean?
Be Way more fucking difficult to banging
a real fucking human being and then
there will just become extinct. All
right. Overrated versus underrated.
Overrated. Giving a shit
bill. I just turned 35,
six months ago and I realized how great
life can be when you start to only care
about shit that pertains to you.
Oh,
I thought that that doesn't to be like
give a shit caring about your fellow man.
This is completely for me.
This is the other way. Um,
I don't care about anything anymore.
And my friends and family say they
really enjoy my company more these days.
I wasn't yoga or Tony Robbins.
It wasn't yoga at Tony Robins.
No disrespect to either of them.
It was apathy. Uh, all right.
Maybe that's what that fucking 32
year old virgin needs underrated.
Waking up early.
I've been waking up early for the
last two years of my life has changed
drastically.
Everything I talk about doing,
I actually do now and I'm in better
shape than ever because of that. Hey,
you know what?
I'll throw another one.
I'll throw a good fucking
underrated out there. Sausage.
I got this great fucking a butcher,
you know,
a couple of towns over and I
make the drive. I make the drive.
That's how good this fucking butcher is.
And when I go in there,
no, all I ever looked at was to steaks.
I looked at the chops, you know,
the fucking pork chops chicken. And
occasionally I would fuck with the fish,
but I blew right by the sausage.
I was just, I don't know,
I think just never was into it. You know,
it's weird. I'll have sausage on pizza,
I'll have it in an Omelet,
but I never gave a fuck about it.
So it was on the phone with
the lovely Nia and you know,
we'd been going there a lot and we
were kind of running out of options.
We'd done all the stake shit.
We'd done the fucking pork chops.
I don't fuck with veal though.
There's no need.
There's no need to do that to an animal.
You know what I mean?
Just let the thing run around and give
it the old fucking right there, Fred. Um,
anyways, so I was just like, I dunno,
what do you want to get now? It's just,
and I was just sort of, as I was talking
to, I looked over at the sausages, right?
Yeah.
And there was one that looked like this
fucking giant, like a black Porno Dick.
Right? So I look at it and
go, what the fuck is that?
And it said it was short ribs,
sausage with cheese.
So I said, I go near these,
got these fucking porno,
Black Dick look and sausages here
that say this short rib with cheese.
She goes,
get those right.
And I don't know if that sounded delicious
or just she's sick of being with me.
But anyways, I got two of them. Right.
And this is really just become
some big sexual thing. No,
my wife did not have a threesome with
them. We actually had them for dinner. Ah.
So anyways, uh, we came home, cooked
those fucking things up in the skillet,
made some pasta and a little
bit of fucking sauce for it.
And uh, it was fucking
delicious. And now I'm,
now I'm all about it. Now I'm
just thinking, once again,
I want to on the big green egg, I want
to learn how to fucking make a pizza,
right? Maybe just cheat,
get the fucking pizza dough.
I can make it good enough sauce.
I get some fresh cheese and
I'll go down the street,
get the fucking Pono Dick fucking
sausage, right? Paula Lorena,
Lorena Bobbitt, chop it up. Put It on
the fucking, I'm sorry. You know what,
underwriting, you know,
it's difficult, underrated.
Trying to talk about sausage and
not going into the porn world. Um,
I mean, what do you want to
do? Fucking lady looking at it?
It's a giant fucking meat.
All right.
That's the podcast is
a 10 year anniversary.
I want to thank all you guys
for listening to this podcast.
It podcasting in general
has changed comedians lives.
It's such a great way to connect
with you guys. Promote our shows.
I'll be at hilarides
Tuesday and Wednesday. Um,
I've had such a great time doing this.
It's actually helped my standup and, uh,
I'm going to continue doing as long
as you guys fucking listen. All right.
That's it. Here's to another 10
years. I'm a porno sausage. Yeah.
Zip.
Yeah.
All right. I'll check in y'all and you
don't take any shit. Go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you on
Thursday. All right. See you.